giuseppe bettoni merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl or on le disait dans son
école pour certaines régions dans le
pays comme au nord à milan
pourquoi ce choix finalement plutôt que
celui de mettre en place des protocoles
sanitaires strictes
est ce que la question a fait débat la
question a fait beaucoup de débats et
effectivement les éléments testés
nommément les écoles fait on a eu des
règlements différentes dalle est
différent les gens le choix de avoir des
couleurs différentiel plus vite et donc
jaune ou orange a donné la possibilité
aux gouverneurs aux présidents des
conseils régionaux de pouvoir décider
des dates de rentrée partiel ou pas il
faut quand même dire que ça concerne
fortement le lycée que and italy n'est
pas de trois ans mais de 5 ans donc
c'est quand même beaucoup plus
importants comme taille d'étudiants
qu'en france quand vous avez beaucoup
plus d'erreurs et on a eu des régions où
on a permis de rentrer à ça pour cent au
début après l'été après on a fermé
complètement après on a laissé partir
que le 50% après les vacances de noël
mais la différence est due à des taux de
contagion différents d'eux les gens à
région en plis ké lé manière si on avait
déjà des protestations très importante
de la part des élèves du lycée au mois
de novembre
prenons le des élèves qui fais ils
courent sur le trottoir devant l'école
là cette fois ci des élèves de certains
régions ont notamment la lombardie en
total ont réfusé occupé l'école quoique
essayons de le faire en sécurité ils ont
fait des tests
ils ont gardé des licences sécurité mais
ça laisse beaucoup de problématiques par
rapport à ce qu'on veut on veut pas
faire lisons le certaines fois on
tâtonne par rapport à ce que on peut
imaginer de faire alors quelle
conséquence je pense notamment aux
familles les plus défavorisées est ce
que finalement il n'y a pas une
catégorie d'élèves d'enfants qui sont
aujourd'hui livrés à eux mêmes en italie
absolument si d'ailleurs
la raison fondamentale d'une telle
réaction on a des taux d'abandon des
déjà la fin de l'année dernière je ne
vous parle pas donc devant 21 je parle
déjà de la fin de 2020
on avait des taux d'abandon dans
certaines parties de la région de milan
à 60 % c'est-à-dire des professeurs qui
se retrouvaient à distance avec les
classes de 25 personnes et à bulle une
semaine il en avait dix donc vous
comprendrez bien que c'était en daelim
donner à ces affolantes et les élèves
sont et partir des amis des collègues
donc on a vu effectivement ce phénomène
de vouloir sera approprié de l'école les
élèves accusent le gouvernement de leur
voler le futur à leur empêchant d'aller
à l'école c'est quand même des mots
forts c'est une masse très importante
d'étudiants et donc deux familles il y à
des collectifs de famille derrière la
réaction de ses élèves
donc c'est un phénomène important voilà
pourquoi on a beaucoup de débats encore
aujourd'hui alors ici en france on parle
beaucoup à des étudiants qui sont au
bord de la crise de nerfs de la
dépression l'a lui même des quatre
suicides
qu'est ce qu'il en est en italie comment
vivent les étudiants dans quel état
d'esprit sont il est est ce que le
gouvernement les aide à surmonter cette
épreuve
il n'y a pas d' aides directes si vous
voulez par rapport à ça il y à une sorte
de observations attention particulière
de la part du corps professoral de mes
profs de lycée fondation cherche à sucre
mais j'ai interpellé certains de mes
collègues du lycée qui me disent au bout
d'un moment tu cherches les contacté
téléphoniquement ballan qui arrive pas
et qui a des élèves qui sont totalement
allongé sur le canapé pendant une
journée selon les les parents hop vous
dites bien il à certains des parents qui
ont moins de moyens l'internation sur
leurs enfants et de essayer de le
travailler mais c'est vrai que on a un
taux d'abandon qui est lié à l'aspect
psychologique aussi très important donc
il ya un danger
on n'a pas encore que je sache des cas
de suicides fort heureusement mais on
n'est pas moi
kate pour autant en quelques mots est ce
que le gouvernement d'unité nationale de
mario draghi compte trouver une solution
en ce qui concerne les écoles est ce que
le sujet sur la table le sujet
absolument cet ancien et 5 pivot du
gouvernement tradi l'école le loto de
l'école le col et le futur du pays
donc il est sans doute un élément clé
alors il faudra attendre le comprendre
de quelle manière parce qu'on a déjà
connu tellement d'actions qui ont été
les coups d'épée dans l'eau
donc il faudra maintenant voir si on va
en avoir des gens qui sans être encore
plus efficace certains ont été de bons
comme action sur 40 aides est beaucoup
moins bonne on le verra mais il est sans
doute un élément au coeur de l'action du
gouvernement tradi merci beaucoup mieux
et paix bettoni d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin je le rappelle vous
êtes politologue à l'université tor
vergata de rome
[Musique]